let's stick with the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 why don't we try the 6 8 2 area
code caller from 6-8 - I'd love to hear
who this is i hi this is thomas thomas
miller again all right go ahead thomas
lee we talked when I asked you about
like all right limits to freedom of
expression I take your word for that
anyways I really dislike Alex Jones and
I live in Texas I was wondering if you
could also send me a bumper sticker too
because about that far away from Austin
and so what what Thomas Miller is
referring to is that our viewer in
Rochester covered up an Alex Jones
bumper sticker with the david pakman
show bumper-sticker which i was told
that is actually considered property
event it's vandalism yeah I didn't know
that so you know it was all shtick for
the air it was none of it was real it
was all theater oh we're not encouraging
crimes
if authorities ask but so we're let me
ask you Thomas just because you live
near Alex Jones that's one thing but
what would you do with the bumper
sticker if I sent it to you maybe attach
it to his car that would be pretty funny
Alex Jones his car you would put a
bumper sticker on Alex Jones's car yeah
and where is his car parked on a regular
basis good question yeah do you think do
you think you'd need to find the car to
put a bumper sticker on it most likely
also I'd probably leave him like a can
of chili too so you forget about at all
you'd leave a can of chili yeah all
right Thomas let's work on this I think
it's a great idea but let's keep a
workshopping it back and forth and once
we get it to where it needs to be it
will participate yeah we can't do that
it's one thing to cover up an Alex Jones
bumper sticker yeah it's another thing
to vandalize property yes which were
against something that doesn't have
something on already yeah he's different
there absolutely all right Thomas thank
you very much
I think we're getting
it's an interesting day I think because
of this heavy snow we're getting a
situation on the phone